hi so this is the second part of my
proposed three part series on political
correctness
looks like I'll probably expand that but
this one deals with the Department of
Human Resources policy to make anti
racism and anti bias training mandatory
among Human Resources staff at the
University of Toronto and I want to
explain a couple of things to you in
relationship to that mostly why I think
it's extremely ill-advised policy but
also a little bit more about political
correctness in general and also about
why you should care about this even
though it doesn't directly affect you or
at least in principle it doesn't
directly affect you so the first thing I
would say is in order to talk about or
any more about political correctness I
guess I probably have to justify my
belief that such a thing exists and I
can tell you have already done some
empirical research on that we did this
psychometrically which is psychometrics
is the science of psychological
measurement and so we took an agnostic
view to begin with and and the question
was well are there a set of political
beliefs that aggregate together so that
they could be described using a single
term such as political correctness what
are the personality and other predictors
of those beliefs and do how do they
associate with other classical forms of
political belief like liberalism and
conservatism because the Conservatives
often assume that political correctness
is a extreme form of liberalism so we're
also interested in whether or not that
was true and so basically what we found
was first yes that there are beliefs
that aggregate together coherently in a
manner that would make it reasonable to
bring them under a single bring them
under the umbrella of a single term
there's actually two dimensions that
seem to be associated with political
correctness and one is radical
egalitarianism and the other is I would
say it's kind of left-wing
authoritarianism it's the desire to use
censorship and language control to to
read to to obtain certain kinds of
political lands we also found out that
the fundamental personality trait that
predicts adherence to such belief is
trait agreeableness and that does
differentiate political correctness from
liberalism say because the fundamental
traits that seem to be associated with
liberalism
the opposite ones are associated with
conservatism liberals are higher in
trade openness and lower in trait
conscientiousness and I'm speaking of
traits in a Big Five manner there are
five cardinal personality traits there's
lots of information about that on my
website if you're interested in that but
the personality predictors of political
correct belief are not the same as the
personality predictors of liberal belief
or at least their substantive difference
so anyways there is such a thing as
political correctness from from a
technical perspective so it's perfectly
reasonable to talk about it and it's not
merely an invention of the of the you
know a politically motivated invention
of the enemies of such of such doctrines
so not as far as I can tell anyways we
will eventually publish that next thing
question is is well why should you care
about what's happening at the University
of Toronto human resources department
and I think there's a number of reasons
for this and the first is that it's a it
offers a real-world case study and
that's really important because you want
to talk about something like political
correctness and what might be done about
it at the level of high resolution and
high detail and so you imagine if
something's gone wrong with a military
military helicopter which is a very
complicated device you don't want a four
year olds drawing of a military
helicopter as a guide to how to fix it
you want a detailed schematic and the
thing about real-world case studies is
they give you detailed schematics and so
we're going to take this particular
occurrence apart very carefully I'm
going to describe to you what I think
its significance is and what the errors
are in the conceptualizing a
conceptualization underlying the policy
so we're going to talk through it very
carefully the other thing I would say is
that HR departments are doing this sort
of thing in many organizations in many
organizations it's the HR department
that's the vanguard of political
correctness and that's in private and
public organizations is alike and and
that it's not this is not something that
by any means is limited to universities
and so I would also like to say that you
you might want to write this off by
saying well the university is a bubble
and the things that have there have no
bearing on the rest of society and
that's a really foolish thing to think
because the university trade trains the
leaders of tomorrow I know that sounds
like a cliche but I mean it
quickly the smart kids that are in
university right now are the kids that
in 15 years are going to be running the
world and so what's happening in the
Universities is an indication of the
shape of things to come and so and I
think the universities are in large part
responsible for the wave of political
correctness that has rolled across North
America and and and and and much of
Europe as well and I think but I'll talk
about all that at a different time but I
want I just want to say to begin with is
don't be thinking that the universities
are isolated from from the real world
because they're not they're not isolated
from the world at all so and they're not
nearly as much of a bubble as you might
think so alright so here we're going to
go to the the memo first so this memo
was set sent out to all the HR staff at
the University of Toronto on September
26 2016 and it was sent out by Angela
Hillyard who's the vice president human
resources and equity okay and so here's
here's the here's the content dear
colleagues next month we will be
providing mandatory anti-discrimination
and anti bias training for all staff in
the division of human resources inequity
and the HR of divisional offices
motivated by conversations that have
taken place over the past year with the
black liberation collective and
racialized staff members of our
community this training is intended to
build and reinforce the work already
occurring throughout the organization
and within human resources recognizing
that there is room for improvement to
embed common understandings and
evidence-based best practice within our
work the training will be co-presented
by Tana Turner I hope I have that right
principal at Turner Consulting Group and
Merlin Charles concurrent teacher
education program Ontario Institute for
the studies of Education so easy that's
the place that trains all our teachers
there will be six sessions hosted for
all human resources staff throughout
October 2016
note that six sessions ok you will
receive a registration link soon to
attend one of the training sessions
hosted on the st. George campus I ask
that all colleagues working there's
three campuses on the University of
Toronto they're somewhat distributed
around the city so
people are being asked to come to the
central campus in order to to finish the
training please note that this is
required training for all HR staff at
the University of Toronto and we will be
tracking attendance and completion
versus via HR is which I guess is
obviously their attendance and
completion tracking system so it's
mandatory and and there's much made of
that that it's mandatory if you have
questions please contact Erin Jackson
executive director I HR okay so
fundamentally Human Resources staff at
the University of Toronto are now
required to attend anti-racist and anti
bias training six sessions and they have
it the attendance is mandatory okay so
why is that a problem
well I think there's actually eight
problems with it I'm going to go through
them in detail the first problem is the
assumption of racism and bias at the
University of Toronto well because if
there's no racism and bias problem at
the University of Toronto then why
bother with it at all so that's one
assumption another another problem not
an assumption is what is in my
estimation the questionable legitimacy
of the groups and individuals who are
serving as consultants to the University
of Toronto human resources department
and we already identified them one of
them was Tana Turner Turner and the
other was Merlin Charles and we'll talk
about them momentarily
oh yes and also the black liberation
collective because the the HR people
have been consulting with the black
liberation collective so these are
people now who have been deemed
appropriate to advise the university in
its internal policies okay third
assumption that I think is problematic
the assumption that anti racism and anti
bias training is the way to address
racism and bias at the University of
Toronto assuming it exists because it
that's quote that that hypothesis can be
questioned the willingness to introduce
what is clearly politicized training or
or could easily become that into the
workplace and on a university campus
which I would think would be the last
place where such things should be done
casually let's say the fifth problem is
assumption of guilt on the part of the
HR staff the sixth problem is the
assumption
that such training should be mandatory
vii problem is the assumption that the
people hired have the competence to
conduct such training that's obviously
linked to my earlier point about
questioning whether or not the people
who are being consulted to make the
policy to begin with have the competence
and authority necessary Authority
legitimacy to to to to promote such
policies and then finally the assumption
that such training will make the
situation assuming there is a situation
that needs to be addressed better rather
than worse all right so that's eight
problems and we're going to take we're
going to take a very close look at each
of them I think if even one of those
problems is is is properly formulated as
I see it that that's enough of a reason
to question the validity of this policy
but I believe that all eight of these
problems exist and they're thorough each
that serious so and you can make up your
own mind about whether you believe that
once you hear the argument all right so
first let's start with the assumption of
racism and bias at the University of
Toronto well the first thing I would say
is that you can if you compare any
organization to a hypothetical utopian
ideal then you can be sure that it will
fall short and I would say however that
comparing any organization to a
hypothetical utopian ideal is a very
dangerous thing to do because if you if
you're cognizant of the history of the
20th century you know that there are
certain dangers associated with utopian
political idealism and that what utopian
political idealists do is to pause it
some perfect state and then denigrate
every organization that human beings
have ever managed to produce on the
basis that it's not up to that level of
perfection
so yes compared to utopia the University
of Toronto has its problem but we're not
going to do that we're going to compare
it to actual real other places and so
we're going to think about this alright
so if you picked a country that was the
hallmark of let's call it tolerance and
I mean reasonable tolerance if you if
you if you wanted to identify a country
that exemplified that above all else in
the world there'd be a few contenders
but Canada would definitely be in that
list okay so we're a tolerant culture
and then Ontario I would say within
Canada
is one of the is one of the more liberal
provinces more liberal tolerant
provinces and it's very very
multicultural and ethnically diverse and
that's particularly true of Toronto
which prides itself rightly or wrongly
on being the most multicultural city in
the world in Toronto is a great city ban
it's big gets exciting it's developing
well it's got a booming economy and
everyone who comes here seems to get
along and that's great and I don't know
why that is but partly it's because the
city is embedded in Canada and Ontario
and Toronto's doing some good things so
hooray for that and then within Toronto
you have the University of Toronto and
that the campus is so multi-ethnic and
racially diverse that I would I would
challenge anyone to find an institution
anywhere in the world that has those
attributes more firmly in place than the
University of Toronto so then so I don't
see that there's a there's a problem
with with racism and bias at the
University of Toronto and I got to point
out that measurements a real issue here
you know because you have to figure out
and I'm speaking from a technical
perspective what is how it is that you
measure racism and asking people
individuals if they think there is
racism isn't a reasonable way of doing
it I can tell you partly why that is if
if you ask people to what degree they
have their group has experienced racism
in a given context or in a given culture
they'll generally report a fairly high
degree of racism but if you ask them how
much they as individuals have suffered
from racism or other forms of bias the
estimates are much lower and so that's
just one indication of the measurement
difficulty that that is part and parcel
of trying to deal with something as
complicated as racism it's mean first of
all exactly what you mean what do you
mean by racism that's a tricky thing and
second how exactly do you measure it so
you know what degree of racism there is
and you have to do that before you you
run around deciding that there's so much
racism that people need to be educated
it's a technical problem and I can tell
you that if I conducted a research study
that was reviewed by the University of
Toronto Ethics Board on an organization
which are not very fond of by the way
but assuming I wanted to do a research
project of this sort I can tell you I'd
have to have a lot better measures of
racism than the measures that the HR
Department is using to accuse their own
staff of sufficient racism to just to to
necessitate training so that's something
to think about there the black
liberation collective which is the group
one of the groups that the U of T has
hypothetically being consulting with
claims that U of T is a racially biased
entity because we don't it doesn't have
as many black people in its in its
faculty and administration as you would
expect to be there if you use the census
as a guideline but you know you you
can't do that because there's all sorts
of reasons other than racism why a
population might be underrepresented in
an organization and and it also ignores
the broader context so for example if
you're if you're thinking about non
census related representation at the
University of Toronto and you're going
to use that as a hallmark of
discrimination you're really in trouble
because there's way more women than men
students say for example in the
humanities there's way more men in this
in the in the sciences and technology
the hard sciences so to speak there's
more Jews among the faculty or the and
that's almost always the case among
faculty because Jewish people tend to be
over-represented in disciplines where
intellectual prowess is is valued
there's more Asians on campus in in
mathematics and say then there are then
you would estimate from the census
preference or the census data so it's
like if we're going to use census data
as the hallmark of of representation at
the University we've really got a lot of
problems and we're going to have to get
rid of a lot of people who have
positions that are already members of
what are often regarded as minority so
it's an insane policy also over older
people are all obviously
over-represented among the faculty in
the administration but that doesn't mean
necessarily that there's that it's
because of bias you know because of bias
of the same sort that you would
associate with racism and then well
there's all sorts of problems associated
with that and if it's black people who
are underrepresented well which black
people are we going to try to try who's
which black people are are we going to
try to rep
present more specifically are we going
to use recent immigrants I mean recent
black immigrants into the United States
for example tend to do better than
multi-generational bloc inhabitants of
the US so you might say well the people
who are really being what biased against
or are the people who are the
multi-generational inhabitants black
multi-generational inhabitants of North
America and like this third thing can be
infinitely fractionated it's not helpful
and we'll never get a precise
representation by census in any
institution it's a stupid way of
thinking about it anyways second I don't
think that the groups that are
consulting with the University of
Toronto HR people are legitimate not
they're not they're legitimate as groups
and they're legitimate as people who
have a perspective but they're not
legitimate as people who should be
consulted on with regards to policy at
the University of Toronto because
they're by no means theirs they have no
legitimacy among the people that they
purport to represent no not none of the
kind of legitimacy that we recognize as
legitimacy like in a democracy you
recognize elected representatives for
example as legitimate represent a
representative so they're there
negotiating with thee or consulting with
the black liberation collectives
primarily aus group the racial situation
in Canada and the racial situation in
the United States are not the same at
all so this is as far as I can tell it's
a spillover of what are fundamentally
American problems into the Canadian
political scene I'll talk more about the
black liberation collective shortly and
also racialized members of the U of T
community and I wasn't even sure what
racialized members mean because I guess
I'm not capable of keeping up with a rep
constant rapid transformation of
politically correct terminology so I had
to look it up it's a sociological term
which doesn't really surprise me because
I think sociology is fundamentally a
corrupt discipline there's a variety of
corrupt disciplines on university
campuses and sociology is certainly one
of them um racialization or ethnicity is
the process of ascribing ethnic or
racial identities to a relationship
social practice or group that did not
identify itself as such well that
doesn't seem to be the definition that
the HR
people are using so I looked at the
Ontario Human Rights Commission website
because it come up on very quickly in
the Google search and not surprisingly
because it's it's an appalling website
in a multitude of ways and the Ontario
Human Rights Commission says recognizing
that race is a social construct the Oh
HRC describes people as a racialized
person or racialized group instead of
the more outdated inaccurate terms
racial minority visible minority person
of color or non-white and I mean it
wasn't very long ago that that as far as
I can remember that visible minority and
person of color were the correct
socially are the correct politically
correct terms but you know they change
very very rapidly and the reason for
that is that if you keep changing the
terms you can keep playing the stupid
politically correct game that's at least
one reason and I said I'll make a video
on the nature of the PC game be a short
video and so but one of it one of one of
the rules of the game is keep changing
the terminology so everyone's always at
fault so anyways I guess what consulting
with racialized members of the U of T
community means is that the U of T
somehow are consulted let's say I don't
know how they would define who
constituted a minority on the University
of Toronto campus because like I said
it's a very multi-ethnic it's a very
very multi-ethnic campus it's not
obvious at all on first its it's not
obvious at all who's who's
underrepresented and who's
over-represented but I suppose it's
probably the the over-represented people
would certainly be black or white
middle-class males I suspect the people
they're probably not very happy about I
mean those guys are on their way out
anyways and and males in general are on
the way out in the university so it's
not going to be a problem if it's a
problem now it's certainly not going to
be a problem for very long so so anyways
I don't think that those groups are
particularly legitimate as as I'm
speaking more particularly of the black
liberation collective racialized members
of the UT community is so vague that I
don't know exactly you know I can't
understand I can't get a handle on the
standing of those people and I don't
know how what they did was measure their
and and and I don't understand the
validity of the constructs that are
there being applied to the to these
particular groups okay let's look at the
black liberation collective who are they
we this is from their website we are a
collective consisting of black students
who are dedicated to transforming
institutions of higher education through
unity coalition building direct action
and political education okay well fair
enough I suppose if that's what they
want to do that's what they want to do
it's I don't know exactly what they're
aimed at with regards to transforming
institutions of higher education through
unity coalition building etc it's a
typical activist group as far as I can
tell and as as you would expect from a
typical activist group they don't
negotiate
they have demands they have national
demands and campus demands and so they
make demands to universities across
North America and the universities are
appallingly willing to to kowtow to
those demands without I think without
sufficient thought and merely as a
consequence of mostly as a consequence
of fear and the desire to be you know
viewed as always being on the side of
moral virtue without having to undertake
the thought necessary to actually ensure
that that is where you're standing so
here's some of the demands oh sorry I
have to tell you a bit more about the
liberation collective I couldn't find
them on Wikipedia weirdly enough I know
that they demanded segregated spaces at
several universities that segregated
spaces can I say that again
they demanded segregated spaces at
several universities including UCLA and
New York University they wanted black
people only to be living together and
queer people only to be living together
and they also demanded safe spaces at
Oberlin College so that gives you some
indication of the sorts of things that
they're up to okay third assumption a
third assumption the HR department is
making is that anti-racism and anti-bias
training is the way to address the
hypothetical racism and bias problem at
the University of Toronto and this
brings up a whole this opens a whole
multitude of cans of worms which is a
lot of cans of worms first of all as I
said it's very very difficult to measure
something like racism and bias
extraordinarily difficult especially
bias and it that's a rat's nest of fear
of three
radical and empirical investigation
particularly in social psychology and
there's some terrible things happening
there so they're very difficult things
to measure and so but you don't only
have to measure racism and bias to to
indicate that such things exist in a in
a university you have to indicate not
only that they exist but that they exist
and that they're causing problems of a
certain magnitude and then that you have
to also pause it that the problems that
such things are causing if they exist
are the most compelling problems that
need to be exist it needs need to be
addressed because you have to address
problems one at a time in terms of their
importance and so you need a ranking so
let's say there is racism at the
University of Toronto and I suppose
there is some because there's some
everywhere that doesn't validate just
because there is some doesn't mean that
this is where our efforts should be
devoted as a university and the
universities put a lot of resources into
this sort of thing and I think in an
ill-advised way and they're paying an
awful lot of money and they're paying
the staff that are doing this a crazy
amount of money especially in comparison
to their what would you call it
credentials seriously it's it and that's
a good indication of the actual what
would you call it the actual value
hierarchy of the university so it isn't
obvious to me that the University of
Toronto's primary function is to address
racism on the on the on the University
of Toronto campus so especially well
I've already made that point you have to
measure and define racism and bias you
have to measure and define the the you
have to define what your training
program is going to look like and
hypothetically why it will work and what
elements will work then you also have to
assess the outcome and I don't see any
of that happening properly with with
with the way that the human resources
department is going about this
particular training program and as I
said already I would not be allowed as a
researcher at the U of T to conduct this
as an intervention in an experiment it
would violate the ethics provisions that
the U of T uses to restrict its
researchers so it looks like it's okay
to inflict on your employees but it
wouldn't be okay for scientists to ask
people to volunteer for for example so
all right so the point here is that
there's no evidence
that anti-racism and anti-bias training
actually lowers racism and bias okay
it's a supposition it might be true but
it might not be true and for all we know
that it would actually increase it and
all good but I'll go back to that okay
so the next issue is should employers
especially employers at public
universities be allowed to enforce
political training enforce training
that's politically motivated on their
employees and you know maybe you could
debate whether or not this constitutes
political training but I think it does
and even and if it doesn't it's close
enough to it so that it it it it should
be discussed at least as a potential
problem so I don't think that employer
should be allowed to politically
indoctrinate let's use that word or even
educate for that matter although I don't
see any evidence that what the U of T HR
department is doing actually qualifies
as education I don't think that an
employer should be allowed to
indoctrinate its employees on pain of
the threat of job loss and you know the
fact that this particular training
program is mandatory and and that that
said a couple of times and that
attendance will be taken indicates to me
an implicit threat that you know your
your your employment viability is going
to be judged
to some degree depending on whether or
not you go attend these seminars so I
don't think that's acceptable at all and
this looks very political to me the
these ideas are associated with radical
left ideology the the people who are
promoting this use highly politicized
language and all of it's predicated on
the fundamental assumption that group
based oppression is everywhere and that
should be the primary consideration of
of social policy and economic policy and
and organizational policy even in places
like the University so that looks all
political to me so this is the worst one
I think probably okay so let's look at
it this way so let's say I'm an HR
person at the University of Toronto and
I get this memo and here's the problem
so I decide that I'm going to here's
what the memo presumes
presumes that the that I'm sufficiently
racist first of all that my membership
in the HR department is the Cardinal
element here about which my guilt or
innocence with regards to racism can be
adjudicated because the fundamental
presumption is that as a group the HR
department people are sufficiently
racist and biased so that they need
reeducation okay so that to me is the
presumption of it's two problems with
that
it's first of all its group based its
group identity based and second of all
it's the presumption of guilt before
innocence right so and so that means
that if I accede to this if I agree to
go to this that I am acting out the
proposition that I am in fact
sufficiently guilty of racism and bias
so that I need to be re-educated well I
don't think that it's reasonable for the
HR department to assume that its staff
is guilty of such nefarious things so
and I think it violates a fundamental
wet a fundamental presupposition that's
at the bottom of the Western legal code
and at Western culture and the freedom
that goes along with that and that's the
assumption of innocence you're innocent
until proven guilty and you're innocent
even if you have even if there's
reasonable doubt about your guilt and
you also have the right to reasonable to
a thorough thorough defense and so I
think it's reasonable for any given HR
person to say hey look I'm not
sufficiently racist to be rated and I
don't think that it's appropriate for
you to be implying that I am and I don't
think that it's appropriate for you to
demand that I attend and I don't think
it's appropriate that you hold out the
possibility of punishment if I don't
attend so and there's something even
worse that's associated with this is
that and we'll get to this in more
detail is that there's an idea that's
become very very popular and it's partly
a consequence of a certain brand of
social psychology associated with an
idea called or with the test called the
implicit association test and that is
the idea that people are characterized
by unconscious racism and bias the thing
is that might be true but that's not
really relevant because where everyone
is guilty of all sorts of things
unconsciously and structurally and that
isn't how you judge the innocence or
guilt of some what and
besides that we don't understand things
like unconscious bias and unconscious
racism anywhere near well enough or are
able to measure anywhere near well
enough to start assuming that we can
start making statements and educating
people out of their unconscious biases
it's an unbelievably unbelievably
dangerous idea and it's an absolute
misuse of social science a terrible
misuse of social science and I should
say that it's it's coming out of social
psychology yes bye and done and that
research has been done by some of the
top researchers in the field of social
psychology and right now the field of
social psychology is under tremendous
attack for the fundamental poor quality
of its scientific investigations so
that's all very much worth thinking
about so and to me the once we allow the
idea that unconscious racism and bias
constitutes a form of guilt and here's
the road we're walking down you can be
punished or threatened for the
possibility of your guilt which means
you're the sort of person that could
conceivably do something about which you
could be held guilty for and you know
everyone's like that because you know
everyone has a dark side that's for sure
and but we can't be punished
because we have dark sides we can be
punished because we express those in
illegal actions not and you don't punish
people or fix them up until they've
actually broken the law not because they
might break the law everybody might
break the law so if the rule is if we
might break the law we should be
punished to re-educated then everyone
should be punished to re-educate it and
that's unless you want to be punished or
re-educated that's not a very good idea
I think it's even worse is that we could
be punished or re-educated for the
possibility that we might have the
intent to do something so so the level
of abstraction of guilt here is becoming
truly truly absurd and it's truly
dangerous here is the entire human
rights commission again to need a
terrible quote about something if you
need a quote - about that will help you
support your assumption of creeping
authoritarianism on the left all you
have to do is go to the Ontario Human
Rights Commission website and they will
give you something you need every time
and Brewer Chua Lee every sentence
racism can be openly displayed in racial
jokes or slurs and slurs or hate crimes
yeah well so much for for all sorts of
comedians I mean Toronto has a very very
very famous comedian who does nothing
but racial jokes and
I mean people loved him people from
races all over the from from every race
you can possibly imagine flock to his
show to be insulted by him because it's
such a relief for someone to state
straight-out such things instead of
instead of and make a joke about them
instead of walking down this particular
path that people are relieved and happy
to see it happen openly I can't remember
Russell Peters that's the guy and so as
far as I can tell what Russell Peters
does is becoming close to illegal and
you know Russell Peters is a pretty damn
funny guy and so and to think of him as
a racist is absolutely insane and you
know and there was a comedian already in
Canada who was fined $40,000 by the
Quebec Human Rights Commission for I
mean he said some nasty things and but
that's not the point he's a comedian
leave the damn comedians alone right
there like the gestures in the Kings
Court they're allowed to say what they
want to say so that we can keep stupid
things and crooked things out where
everybody can pay attention to them
anyways racism can be openly displayed
in racial jokes and slurs or hate crimes
but can be more deeply rooted in here we
go
attitudes values and stereotypical
beliefs good luck defining them and what
will happen is they'll be defined in a
way that maximizes people's guilt
because that's the way you can keep the
PC game going as I said in some cases
these are unconsciously held oh good so
now we're going to be held liable for
our unconscious biases very very bad
idea especially because we just do not
understand things very well we can't
measure them very well we don't
understand them very well there's a lot
of debate about what they are and even
if they do exist in the way that people
claim we don't know what to do about it
and like it conscious retraining
programs there's no evidence that
conscious retraining programs are going
to are going to fix this this sort of
thing so or if there is evidence I
certainly don't know it and worse and if
there is evidence I don't think the
people who are doing the re-education
programs demanded by the HR people have
demonstrated that their particular
programs have the positive benefit
that's being claimed
okay next is the assumption that such
training should be mandatory well you
know that reeks to me of again of
creeping authoritarianism it's like not
only are you biased and racist and you
don't get to say so anything about that
we're just going to assume it right off
the bat but you better believe well go
to the training and if you don't there's
going to be a problem for you
okay well anybody if you all you have
why not make it voluntary why not make
it volunteer why not ask people you know
maybe you get a 95% show rate but then
of course it wouldn't be the real
racists that would go you don't know
that you don't know that you could ask
your people to go in fact you could ask
them to go and see if anybody showed up
because you would also be able to judge
that way if there's any interest in it
but oh no we're going to force people to
go we can impose our particular
political perspective on them we're
going to accuse them of guilt we're
going to punish them if they don't if
they don't go along with our mandate
that's the policy even though we have no
evidence that this is going to work okay
now more another one the competence and
impartiality of people hired as trainers
okay so let's say that there is a
problem with racism and bias at the
University of Toronto which which I
don't believe and or at least I don't
believe it's enough of a problem so that
it should be like so high up the
hierarchy of problems that we're trying
strenuously to fix as an imperfect
organization as far as imperfect
organizations goes it's a pretty good
one okay so fine let's say that this
racism and bias does exist even though I
don't think the evidence for that is
there well then the question is well who
are the people that are coming in to do
the training because I can tell you this
is tantamount to a psychological it's
certainly it's tantamount to a
psychological intervention and so then
you might think well are the people who
are conducting this sort of intervention
qualified to do so and one of the things
you'd hope is that they have the right
credentials and the second is that you'd
hope is that they had published
something you know in a respectable
journal that had been peer reviewed
indicating that their particular
training program actually reduced racism
in a in a cost-effective and measurable
manner instead of increasing it for
example because you know there's always
the possibility that a well-meaning
intervention will make things worse and
we will get to that in a moment so we're
going to look at the two people who are
hired as trainers and we're going to all
just tell you about them and you can
draw your own conclusions okay so the
first one is Tana Turner her
qualifications are a master's degree in
sociology and as I said already
sociology is one of those disciplines
that I at least regard as fundamentally
corrupt and so I don't think that that
constitutes qualification she worked in
public service on provincial employment
equity legislation she's responsible for
work identifying specific groups to be
designated for employment equity twelve
years as an independent consultant
providing Human Resource diversity
equity research program evaluation and
community consulting expertise to a
range of clients all right she's the
principal at Turner Consulting Group so
she does this this is a this is her
primary occupation and she is an equity
diversity and inclusion consultant she
offers their offers clients a
comprehensive approach to help them
understand their changing employee
population client base and how to
leverage that diversity for
organizational success because of course
one of her presuppositions is that
diversity defined in the politically
correct manner is a precondition for
organizational success even though I
don't think that there's any literature
bearing on that that that indicates that
that's the case
all right here's some of the things that
she claims and thinks inclusion goes
beat goes beyond having a diverse
workforce and complying with equity
related legislation as important as
these things are an inclusive
organization can be defined as an
organization that integrates the values
of equity and diversity because those of
course are the top two values within all
aspects of the organization including
policies and procedures as well as
individual behaviors and organizational
culture so in my estimation she's
someone who fundamentally holds
politically correct beliefs and the
reason she's hired by the people who
hired them hire her is to spread those
beliefs as white as widely as possible
within the organization and now at the
University of Toronto that will be
mandatory and though there are implicit
punishments waiting in the wings for
people who aren't really happy about
doing that so
a diverse workforce includes people of
different races cultures religions ages
sexes abilities and sexual and gender
identities at all job levels yeah well
that's one way of defining diverse I
mean I guess I would think more about
what constitutes a competent and
effective workforce but that is a
secondary consideration I would say it
is a secondary consideration at the
University of Toronto at least in the
administration as far as I've been able
to tell that doesn't mean it isn't a
consideration but we don't see this kind
of discussion about competence and
excellence which is what I discuss what
a university should really be aiming at
right they're institutions of excellence
and the idea that excellence is best
served by this kind of diversity is a
it's a specious specious at least it's a
highly debatable claim I don't think
there's any evidence for it whatsoever I
mean it's hard diversity is seen by the
organization and its employees as a
source of strength and creativity says
it's seen by the organization of its
employees as a source of strength and
creativity that doesn't mean it is a
source of strength and creativity I can
tell you I know the creatively
creativity literature very well and I
know the productivity literature pretty
well and I don't think that there's any
evidence at all that for example
diversity produces an increment in
creativity creativity seems to me to be
seems to be fundamentally a like it's a
cardinal personality trait that's
associated with openness it's also
associated with high intelligence it's
actually quite rare and there's no
evidence whatsoever that that like
diversity increases workplace creativity
not that I know of
adding to the effective and efficient
delivery of sever's services to a
diverse client population well those are
stated as facts and I don't think
there's I think the evidence for them is
weak at best and non-existent at worst
and and that they're sorry that false
they're those are false claims at worse
the evidence for them is is non-existent
at best or weak an inclusive
organizational culture is one in which
the values of equity diversity inclusion
see those have got to be the only values
and I can tell you as well that those
are associated with trade agreeableness
so basically what these these ideologies
are expressions of the underlying
personality trait they're like the mouth
the the ideological expression is the
mouthpiece of the trade and
people are very high in traits like
agreeableness are very likely to hold
this sort of value structure and then
they're positing it as an absolute it's
not an absolute because there are at
least five dimensions of personality
that are associated with values that are
necessary for people to live a balanced
life so again that's a specious claim an
inclusive organizational culture is one
in which the values of equity diversity
inclusion are reflected in both the
formal structure and in the informal
practices and norms okay so her basic
claim is that what she's going to do is
to come in and help you ensure that the
hierarchy of values in your organization
is transformed so that equity diversity
inclusion are at the top and it's not
obvious to me at all that those are the
values that should be at the top of any
given organization and certainly even if
they are among the highest values of an
organization there are many other
organizations many other values that
should be considered at least of equal
importance especially in an organization
like the University of Toronto that in
principle is aiming at excellence in
such an organizational culture all
employees feel respected comfortable and
are able to bring their his or her their
full self to work and have it valued
yeah sure no don't buy it because I
don't think that this emphasis on
diversity equity and inclusion has
helped the employees feel respected
comfortable and valued or that that is
what makes them able to bring their full
self to work and have it valued
propositions not facts not supported by
the data as far as I know research
hasn't been done that would indicate
that any of this is true so as far as
I'm concerned it's basically political
cliche and it's ill-advised at best they
are then able to contribute their best
to the organization yeah it could be but
probably not and I don't think there's
any evidence for it and I know the
literature by the way so if anybody
would like to have a debate about this
I'd be perfectly willing to to do so so
okay next so this is what else she does
to address the governance needs of an
inclusive organization our services
include tools techniques and assistance
such as assessing existing diversity
among board members to establish a
benchmark developing a board recruitment
process that incorporates her definition
of diversity and tailoring board
documents and statements to be more
inclusive so
it's it's the it's the it's the
dissemination of a politically correct
viewpoint through absolutely every level
of the organization we also provide
training to board members and offer
board manuals to help board members
understand and integrate issues related
to her definition of diversity into
their decision-making so that's what she
offers and she worked on her conducted
22 employment systems reviews so that's
how widespread her influences for a
number of private nonprofit and public
sector organizations she also developed
and delivered human rights and here we
go unconscious bias training and what
she actually means by that is training
against unconscious bias and I already
laid out my objections to the idea of
training against unconscious bias really
like this is a terrible thing we do not
understand this anywhere near well
enough for people to go around telling
themselves and offering their services
for sale saying look I can come into
your organization and help your
employees reduce their unconscious bias
and then also to accuse your employees
of having unconscious bias to a degree
that necessitates their retraining
that's an awful thing to do it is the
presumption of guilt before innocence
and it's the presumption it's the
presumption of a kind of guilt that no
one can escape from being accused of
it's absolutely appalling so conducted
program reviews conducted gender equity
analysis etc so anyway so that's the
sort of person who's going to be doing
the training and I guess that's not
really all that surprising next person
is oh one other things so this is Tana
Turner here's one of the things that she
sells on her website it's called
defeating unconscious bias it's a DVD or
a USB it's for the lovely price of seven
hundred and seventy five to eight
hundred and twenty-five dollars
defeating unconscious bias is designed
to address the hidden biases that can
affect hiring promoting and
team-building and to challenge your
ability to create an inclusive workplace
yeah well I don't think so sorry
I don't believe that that's something
that can be done yet and I think that
people who claim that they can do it
well you can make up your own mind about
that alright so next
all right so the final one is the
assumption that training programs of
this type would be effective so let's
assume that there is a problem at the
University of Toronto with racism and
bias even though I don't think there is
not particularly then the next and then
let's assume that the people that that
that we're going to bring people in to
train everyone out of their racism and
bias unconscious or otherwise then we
might have to ensure that we're going to
have to buy the idea that this sort of
training is effective okay well no
problem except here except this so if
you're a clinician and a research
scientists say like me one of the things
that you've learned is that you do not
put in place an intervention without
assessing its outcome and the reason for
that is because there have been well
publicized failures of social science
interventions which I would contend I
would consider this sort of training
exactly that it falls under the same
rubric because it's an educational or a
psychological intervention there have
been well-documented catastrophic
failures of such interventions in the
past one of the most famous one of those
was called the Somerville study which
was done in the 1930s woman named Joan
McCord
a very good criminologist conducted a
lot of the follow-up research to the
Somerville study and the Somerville
study was an attempt to take kids who
are in kind of rough inner-city
neighborhoods and put them through
psychological and sociological
interventions to reduce their risk of
especially of crime in the later years
of their life and actually what happened
was that the intervention although very
carefully designed and I would say
admirably designed and also designed by
people who I did do think had the best
interests of the kids at mine in mind or
at heart my consequences were that the
kids were in the intervention program
actually ended up being more criminal
than the kids that weren't and there's a
large literature on this it was a very
shocking study at particularly the
people who did it it's a classic and and
it's not the only it's not the only
study of its type now I'm posting the
introduction to this book was written by
Joan McCord called crime and family
there's two chapters in that book that's
the selected writings of John McCord
once called the Cambridge Somerville
study a pioneering longitudinal
experimental study of delinquency
prevention and then chapter four is
Cure's that harm on anticipated outcomes
of crime prevention programs well that
could be of any kind of prevention
program so I'll post the introduction so
that you guys can read that but my point
is quite clear you have an intervention
you think there's a problem you design
an intervention well then it's incumbent
on you to demonstrate carefully that the
intention that the intervention produces
its desired effects because there's a
high probability that it won't in fact
there's a high probability that will
produce the reverse effect so for all
the HR department knows their mandatory
training program could make people more
racist and more biased and I would say
the mere fact that the training is
mandatory is highly likely to produce
precisely that outcome because it's
going to generate resentment among
people even people who are going who who
would be relatively unwilling to express
that resentment so my hypothesis would
be as a scientist and a researcher if I
was conducting this as an experiment
that I'd have two conditions voluntary
and mandatory although I wouldn't be
allowed to do that because that would be
unethical by the way according to the
well that would be that would be
unethical research but I would test to
see if mandatory trading and voluntary
training had different effects and my
guess is that mandatory training would
kick back and it would reverse the
effects of the training but we don't
care about that sort of thing when we
put policy like this into place because
we already assume that we know what
we're doing and partly we do that
because we know so little about what
we're doing that we can't even see what
sort of mistakes we might be making we
just make assumptions there is racism we
know where it is we have a training
program the training program will fix
the racism and then things will be
better and it doesn't matter if we make
it mandatory it's like sorry none of
those propositions are viable they're
all debatable they all need to be tested
and they're all dangerous in that they
might produce an unintended consequence
negative consequence and that there's
lots of reason in the literature to
assume that that might be the case so
I'll post that you guys can read it you
can think about it merlin charles so
she's the one along with Tana Turner
who's going to be doing the training
couldn't find out that much about her
she's a sessional lecturer at the
Ontario Institute of Studies on
education I guess I need to say
something about eysie I think that
educational psychology is a
fad ridden discipline I think the level
of scholarship is appallingly low I can
identify a number of fads that that rush
through the education system a lot of it
pushed through by educational
psychologists over the last 20 years the
idea of practical intelligence that's
one of them the idea of whole word
reading which was a catastrophe in the
California school system that was
another the notion that self-esteem
training that self-esteem even exists
which I don't think it does technically
speaking I think it's a variant
fundamentally of trait neuroticism which
isn't really movable there's there's
some reasonable evidence that
self-esteem training turned children
into narcissists rather than increasing
their self-esteem and I don't think
there's any evidence that the
self-esteem programs had the desired
effect so there's a variety of oh and
then there's also the idea of multiple
intelligences which is an absolutely
specious idea from a scientific
perspective so educational psychology is
unbelievably fad ridden and so and oisi
is a major offender in that regard
anyways Merlin Charles's has a PhD in
education and she's and the reason I'm
bringing up the fad ridden issue is
because she's a specialist in what's
called holistic education it's a
philosophy of education based on the
premise that each person finds identity
meaning and purpose in life's through
connections to the community to the
natural world and to humanitarian values
such as compassion and peace which which
which I would say also those values are
reflective of trade agreeableness by the
way especially compassion holistic
education aims to call forth from people
and intrinsic reverence for life and a
passionate love of learning well to me
that's all cliche fundamentally and and
I so the fact that she's a specialist in
holistic education does not indicate to
me that she holds the qualifications
necessary to serve as an advisor to to
policymakers at the University of
Toronto so so why is the University of
Toronto listening to these individuals
and groups I think there is a lot of
reasons for it but I think one of them
is that it's because they effectively
present themselves as oppressed or as
experts in oppression and that's enough
now one of the things we might further
discuss is what value should be being
supported and presented at the
University and right now the PC
onslaught is is predicated on the idea
that the fundamental values are equity
diversity and inclusion and what I find
troublesome about that is twofold is one
that that's a very one-sided hierarchy
of values and I mean that technically
because it's the values that agreeable
people would hold as as sacrosanct and
there's other sets of values that have
to be included in a properly functioning
value hierarchy in order for individuals
and for societies to stay balanced and I
would say that what also needs to be
included at the university are the
values associated with conscientiousness
which would be roughly competence
excellence and quality and also of
openness which is creative free inquiry
and so those have to be considered at
least as important and arguably as more
important the other thing that bothers
me is that the definitions of equity and
diversity and inclusion are defined by
precisely the criteria that the social
justice warrior and PC types believe are
responsible in some sense for all ills
in society and that we're asking were
being required to construe ourselves in
terms of our group identity whatever
that group might be age gender race
ethnicity sexual preference sexual
expression gender expression gender
identity and undoubtedly a plethora of
new terms to come were being asked to
accept those divisions as as as
indicative indicative of the fundamental
differences between us and then to
assume that the only way that that you
can judge whether or not a society is
functioning properly is to determine
whether every person where whether all
of those categories are represented
numerically equally in every single
situation well you know it's a it's a
it's a poor game that and it's part of
the PC game and I'm going to release a
video on the PC game a short one to
exactly what that is so okay so what
might be done about such things that
would be the next question in in this
particular case what should be done well
I would say that HR staff at the
University of Toronto and and also and
people everywhere should refuse to
subject themselves to re-education
regarding their putative racism and bias
unless they want to convict themselves
by attending and I think that's exactly
what they're doing is that if you're
forced to undergo such training and you
agree then by the fact that you attend
you agree that the intervention is
justified and I I know that it's
difficult for people to stand up against
this sort of thing but I don't think
it's as difficult as people presume at
least in impossible in at least possibly
because I think that the people who are
pushing this sort of thing are actually
not very brave I mean they construe
themselves continually as victims and I
have a sneaking suspicion that if people
push back with any degree of firmness
that they would back off very very
rapidly but we need to find out because
these this sort of thing has to be
stopped now it can be still be stopped
by peaceful means and and I don't think
that that's going to be the case in ten
years if things continue the way they
are so it's time for people to stand up
using peaceful means and in here are
some ways you should contact some of the
people in charge and all of your
organization or in this case the
University of Toronto and express your
concern and you should do it you should
say what you have to say in a
cool-headed clear and well articulated
manner and you should assume to begin
with rationality and goodwill on the
part of the recipients you can consider
that assumption and act of courage on
your part if you can't formulate your
own words then you can tell them that
you found the arguments in this video
convincing and maybe you want to
highlight one or two them I gave eight
different arguments you could send them
the link might also be interesting to
ask these people how much the university
is planning to pay for these training
sessions because that's something I'd be
very interested in knowing so I think
it's something that that that's that's a
valid matter matter for public debate
all right and so here's the here's the
connections of the people the contact
information
that would enable you to contact the
people who are responsible for the
policies here they are so the first is
Aaron Jackson he's the executive
director internal resources internal
Human Resources I took a look at her
credentials she has a bachelor's degree
with an advanced certificate from the
Rotman advanced program in human
resources management and I can't see
that that level that level of
qualification ensures that she has the
expertise necessary to evaluate the
effectiveness of the kind of program
that she's considering putting in place
so that's Aaron Jackson she's at erin
dot jackson at you toronto dot CA and
then she works for angela Hillyard who's
the vice president of human resources
and equity angela dot hilde yard at
utoronto dot CA and then finally up
above at the highest plateau is the
president of the university dr. Meric
Gertler
and you can reach him at president at
utoronto dot CA so I would say email
these folks if you email one of them
email all three of them express your
concern and I would also say to the HR
staff that's going to be affected by
this that you should make your
opposition known unless you agree to
convict yourself of your racism and bias
by attending and if enough of you did it
it would come to a halt at least at
least it could be put forward that this
program should not be mandatory okay so
thank you very much for listening and
soon enough I'll put up lecture 3 which
is going to be very pragmatic and
focused lecture on tactics that can be
used to push back against the political
correct against political correct
excesses bye for now